[Music]
don't be a fake don't be a flake don't
run away from your feelings babe don't
be afraid don't be ashamed don't
hesitate to say hey babe hey babe hey
babe hey
[Music]
now with the sleeve
tight around the arm what do you think
this is this is a new look that i'm
going for where it's it's a button down
it's complimentary good material yeah
made by the roosevelts oh at rsvlts on
instagram this is called the canoco
shirt well i mean this is a full-on plug
you that much are you that much behind
this product uh so they send them to you
for nothing or did you pay for that no
they said this would be for nothing but
they're not there but no this one
this one for nothing but then i bought i
no pro i bought them with my own full so
you got a little aztec pattern going on
i like it are you appropriating i don't
know tbd i do feel like i can arizona
iced tea yeah but it's tight on the
sleeves i also have a cold now you've
given me i gave you this it's like an
airborne it's called baroka
and it's just a shot in the chops uh it
supports mental sharpness and physical
energy it's loaded with uh vitamin b and
and c and and uh even got some probably
folic a folic acid in there
flavoring
acid that's what you're supposed to take
if you if
if you're pregnant niacin well don't the
cat's out of the bag but you got biotin
zinc magnesium calcium uh look at this
vitamin b6 you got 588 percent worth
five
what is this how about this thiamin
1 250 percent the recommended time you
know what i want to say from out of all
my friends you probably got the nicest
diamonds
[Laughter]
what's up everybody i'm back on the road
doing stand up go to chrisdcomedy.com
check the website see if your city's on
there we got a lot of shows sold out
we're adding a lot of shows i appreciate
the fan support so much that's
chrisdcomedy.com
vitamin c
and eleven 111
you're daily recommended you're gonna
wait wait wait wait so you're on the
road
mental sharpness okay no i told you one
time i took accidentally took 40 42 000
of my daily recommended vitamin b when
you were out of your out
i swear to god it was like i did so much
cocaine if that's that's what cocaine is
like um is that when you're p
crystallized
no okay p crystallized later on i was
told that in general i'm taking too much
vitamin c knock it down i had a cold and
i went and bought this packet that
looked like emergency but it was a
different brand and i just took it and
after that i was going like
yeah
[Applause]
it was 41 667
i showed you on the spot yeah the
recommended daily allowance so if you
divide 41 000. hold on a second if you
divide 41
41
677
buy a hundred
i took 416 days worth of vitamin d in
one
one afternoon i i used 416 days worth i
mean a year's worth of vitamin b i took
it in one shot i swear to god i didn't
know what i was doing i was it was like
i took a full loco did you sleep
that night or you didn't sleep for a
couple days i was for hours
i felt like i was on like a high dose of
adderall or something like that i was i
was probably jumping in place was it
like borderline scary actually i did it
was it actually was i was like man i
can't believe how i feel right now this
is nuts wow yeah yeah
um and that was like a full logo no
i did a full logo once i like your idea
though that we're going to do one maybe
we'll do an episode or on the patreon
where we line up espresso shots and do a
show i think this is what i think you
know how like sometimes like people will
like oh even you might you do the
edibles right you do edibles
on the christy chaos show on the patreon
we do the chris and eddie show at
patreon.com christy comedy where we do
edibles aka eddies and we call the
christianetti show where we do an edible
and we do the show which you will be a
guest on yes i'm going to be a guest on
patreon you'll guess on the picture but
you can also be guest on the edible show
i know i knew what you guys are saying
where the hell is your patreon the
reason we couldn't do it is because
chris is over there you know in l.a
filming now he's bad but when he comes
back
in just a few weeks i think or something
like this we're going to start it up yes
i know we keep saying it we're going to
do it but you drink that all i need you
to drink that all right to get better i
just gotta get a blower although it's
extremely rare to die from a vitamin
overdose there have been reported
instances of death related to vitamin
toxicity for example hypervitaminosis
uh can be caused by taking one large
dose of over 200 milligrams of vitamin a
or chronic use of more than 10 times the
daily intake 10 times
i took
416 times the intake you actually
cheated death is what how do they sell
that product how do they sell that
product
yeah i don't know do you remember what
the product was it's on my friggin it's
it's like on an instagram and i
instagram the package the the nutrition
facts because after i didn't understand
what happened to me i looked at the
nutrition facts and saw that and i
freaked out and i posted it right
and i don't know how you're allowed to
have 42 000 of something now i've had
this cold for a long time now i've had
it for two weeks you thought it was
allergies but how do i know if it's not
out what how do we know we'll see if i
get sick allergies versus the cold yeah
no but i when i used to have allergies i
could always be like i know this is
allergies but i was saying i knew this
was allergies
but i knew that it was allergies but now
i just told you now i think it could be
a cold you don't know who the suspect is
it's like an episode of murder she wrote
so here what's your sweet shout out
angela lansbury
shout out to jessica what's her name
jessica on the show jessica uh
angelo lansbury was jessica angelo
lansbury murder she wrote
jessica
come on sal
jessica fletcher boom boom boom let me
know
cold verse allergies you ready if you
have a cold sore throat usually
allergies rarely i don't have a sore
throat so we got one in the mar we got
one in the thing for allergies
runny nose usually cold usually
allergies doesn't help check the box
stuffy nose usually cold usually
allergies fever with a cold sometimes
allergy never i don't have a fever
please i hope you don't
i don't have a feve all right
i don't i don't yeah you know you got a
fever i no i don't know i don't have a
fever so right now right now we're
leaning allergies yeah okay okay so if
it's allergies it's allergies yeah
what can you do i don't know you know
who doesn't get allergies oh tom brady
shout out todd brady yeah one won the
super bowl this year he won the tampa
bay but there have been bucks one in
tampa in tampa which is unheard of a
team never gets to play in their home
city let alone the winner of the home
city tom tampa tom did it he's also the
kane tanaka of the nfl yes he is
yes he is and patrick mahomes one of the
youngest hotshot quarterbacks in the
league
runner-up kansas city chiefs he's
already won a super bowl why does he
need another one it's fine yeah good
happens good to go did i tell you i got
the cube in the mail you got the cube i
got the cube i told you i got to keep
yes
because the here okay so what the cube
is it comes out on june 10th or maybe
came out already it's dwayne wade's
this we have not i have not opened this
yet
oh my god yeah i think you actually have
like uh god please don't have something
serious yeah
is there a is this something serious
this could be
the cube
okay
dwyane wade former uh miami heat chicago
bulls basketball player then also on the
miami heat now is hosting a show on tvs
i was on a flight once with dwayne wade
tall guy we went to uh the cayman
islands together he broke out the plane
he's married to um gabrielle union yeah
they were on the flight with me can you
believe that first class
i don't remember
back then i don't think i would be
flying first class to cayman islands
right but maybe i did because we got
free accommodation so maybe i splurged
because there wasn't no way he was in
not in first class he can't but i don't
know if i you know he did walk right
past me and then he was on me and you
know he was in flip-flops and sweats but
he looked like he was in a suit it was
unbelievable interesting it was such
upscale flip-flops and sweats right like
he like like you could tell if you
didn't know who dwyane wade or gabriel
union were you would look at them and be
like these two people are stars stars
yeah or wealthy you know what though you
never know though with a plane because i
once took a flight from kansas city back
to new york and reggie jackson hall of
fame
baseball slugger reggie jackson was in
the very last row next to the bathroom
really on the flight maybe he had to get
on a flight now is the only seat left
yeah
it's good to be frugal now this is going
to look like a plug for this show well
yeah well well listen they sent it to us
i got one sal got one we're excited to
to about to show the cube okay uh
there's a card from dwayne wade here
open it up
these are my rules
wait wait
that was a mouthful from dwayne wade by
the way real quick just want to let you
know celebrities who most who who
usually all the time fly coach kim and
kanye
i can't believe that at all kate
middleton anderson cooper jessica albert
paris hilton and caitlyn jenner
that's
insane that they fly so stupid there's
no way paris hilton flies coach you want
to get out the cube let's get it out i
don't know what even this is i don't
even understand what this is okay here's
the top part
what is going on okay uh i i have a
hypochondria like i think i'm getting
sick right now
i swear to christ i think i'm getting
sick i think i feel like i'm in the sick
yeah yeah hopefully i don't what are we
gonna do though we gotta keep doing the
app it will prove if you have
if you have allergies you're sick of
cold yeah all right what is what it is
if i get if i knew it when i woke up
this morning i was certain it was
allergies as the days progressed i'm on
the fence okay all right
what can we do not much for those of you
listening in i have a plexiglas cube in
my hand i'd say it's about i don't know
five cubic feet
and there's a base that lights up and
there's a bunch of balls red and blue
and then it's a die
i mean this is a this is involved what
what the balls on dwyane wade sending
this to my house i don't have room for
this in the apartment put the cube on
put the cube on watch what happens watch
this
is this disposable or is this for years
we played this for years this is for
years we're gonna play this look at this
watch this
oh it's supposed to light up
mine lit up there you go
lights up okay
that was pretty cool what happens now
though
[Music]
he said it
one player here's here's how you play
player play a game you need a blindfold
several brooms or mops ottoman side
tables or chairs and a timer which is
optional that's not true
we don't just need the cube
end tables and mops
what is this
what is that here's the directions for
the cube set up an obstacle course in
your home placing brooms or mops between
two chairs to create hurdles while
blindfolded attempt to travel from one
end of the room to the other without
knocking the brooms or mops from the
other positions add a time limit to ramp
up the pressure what does it have to do
with the cube who is doing this i mean
this is i mean children supposed to do
this blindfold your children have them
jump hurdles in the middle of the living
room here we go here's another one
remove the cube from its here's another
game called blind shot remove the cube
from its base place the cube open side
up behind a barrier like on the other
side of the couch so that it's not
visible from your point of view attempt
to blindly toss the ball over the
barrier into the cube alternatively
place the cube across the room with no
barrier but attempt while blindfolded
then the last game is called expulsion
fill the cube with an assortment of
balls the more inside the harder the
challenge set your timer 10 to 20
seconds and attempt to scoop all the
balls out of the cube with your hands
before the clock runs out
if you'd like to add balls you can use
the provided balls plus an assortment of
ping-pong tennis and bouncy balls
anyway
so i don't i wouldn't recommend it
are you actually stuck in here it's
[Music]
[Laughter]
it's tight you get it out but it's tight
put it in see what happens
believe your hand is winnie the pooh i
can't even get it in you can't get you
can't maneuver it in
it's it's i just cut my finger
that's from that i don't know that no
that's yesterday
yesterday's cube
yeah i mean here well hold on i'm sorry
i i really want to play i don't
understand what's what this is well they
gave us a 10 second timer from the mu
ask the mus cube timer
um and and i guess
that's got batteries and that's a timer
so how do i even how do i even dispose
of this
where do i put this now it doesn't fit
in a garbage pail
it doesn't fit in my trash in my kitchen
it doesn't fit down the chute so how
often do you get promotional material
like this all the time what do you do
with it not much
this is intriguing see i i just got to
the true tv tbs family with the backyard
bar war show so now i'm starting to get
the products they said i will say
something true tbs so they send one of
really nice gifts during the holidays
during big moments for the show during
our birthdays they always send something
i never know specifically who to thank
if you're watching and we know that you
are thank you
want to say thank you mr true yeah
so you supposed to throw the balls in
the side i guess i don't even know
well what game does tristan play
he he was just throwing he was he was so
what tristan was doing was standing on
the other side of the room and trying to
pitch the ball through the hole
okay i could see that as a kid just
trying to throw a ball through a hole
from across the room he's trying to
throw a ball through the hall and then
he's drinking game yeah and then and
then he put delilah and then we put
delilah in the box i was trying to sit
and she's a contortionist trying to get
in try to get into the box
yeah so that but now
so that's the cube 10 tbs
yeah i guess that's it right yeah i mean
so
i mean what why don't we we should why
does everybody at home just watch the
show
and we send us videos we have no stake
in the show though we got no stake in
the show what has dwayne wade ever done
for me
if dwayne wayne wade has miami heat
championship ring money yeah i'm
promoting the cube for him he's got to
give me something can we shout out hey
babe once maybe once between wait i was
on a flight with you
i'd like to uh how about yeah how how
crazy would it be if like you know
what's gonna eventually happen
is because the the podcast is gonna die
unfortunately yes
the the at this rate she might outlive
me the the the podcast
money the podcasters and really the
youtubers are making so much money i bet
you it's not another realm of
possibility where in our lifetime or
very soon
some like huge youtuber because they
have so much money is going to like
pay enough to like have themselves their
faces like sponsored and stitched onto
like an nba jersey
oh yeah that's going to happen like
logan paul is just going to be on it'll
be like the logan paul center that the
lakers play at yes yeah yes that's going
to happen how great would that be it's a
lot of money those guys are making let
me ask you a question should we just
continue the episode with the cube on
for the rest of the show or is it too
much free
promo even though we're part of the tbs
true tv family i think we did our due
diligence
we wanted to play the game but i don't
know what the game is unfortunately i
don't know what it is and your hand got
stuck in it and i'd rather even though
i'll do anything you know i'm a team
player i'd rather not rip the skin off
my knuckles yeah just to prove a point
if i could get this cube
off of this this lettering i could put
like a football helmet in there and make
it like a display case oh i don't know
what the hell i could like just behead
somebody
you know what i mean could you a mat
that would be funny to put a human head
inside that yeah
next on the cube
all right get that thing out of the way
god bless good luck with the show dwyane
wade yeah i mean we could give that away
to a listener
i don't know
here that cube arrived at my house this
morning it's been six seven days now
seven days since last thursday you've
been saying i've been sick yeah the
cuban arrived at my house this morning i
guarantee you it's broken i bet i would
be will and i will i promise you if this
is true i will film it and we will put
it on the hey babe show it is outside in
front of my house right now and pieces
getting ready to be thrown out into the
garbage i bet you either delilah or
tristan broke it yeah that's funny man
just immediately broke it you try to
sell it didn't we get anything for it no
what would you get for it i'd like to
leave it on like mcdougall street see
what they do with it let's see listen if
you guys want if you want to set up a
camera and just see here we go we just
stopped playing the cube if you want the
cube if you want the cube that's in the
possession of me and sal right now
ten thousand dollars cash
and we'll sign it
we'll sign it
uh we'll throw in a john a like baseball
bat through this through the world
that's worth 200 unsigned unsigned you
ever buy anything off craigslist
no do you know like you know like
craigslist like people go to your house
and stuff yeah what do you mean well
like craigslist but people want to sell
something like i went well okay i went
and bought a crack a treadmill off
craigslist once okay
so craigslist people will be like you
know i got a couch i don't need you know
fifty dollars of best offer 500 the best
offer or come get it take it for free
right whatever you know what i mean
that's how people like a craigslist
usually go to someone's house it's very
you've never done anything yeah never
done anything with chris one time it was
like it was gotta be like uh i want to
say it was like mid 90s okay and i
wanted to buy a treadmill but a
treadmill like out of the store was like
a grand i couldn't afford it so i
perused craigslist for ads and uh
craigslist has been around since the
mid-90s i got it i got to imagine pimp i
didn't think that i thought that craig's
list was way
i thought it came out like 2005.
so you were very early on craigslist you
literally came out in the in the mid 90s
yeah mid to late 90s
did you hear about this with craigslist
where the mobs hiding on it
no mafia hits new low reputed gambino
mobsters charged with running
craigslist's teen prostitution ring
wow you really can't get anything on
craigslist oh craigslist
i would never know to even search for
that on craigslist i usually search for
like
craigslist has a weird underbelly yeah
right couches this is like the original
silk road i think
right
cd
someone told me one time people uh
someone told me like there was like an
ad that they read and they were like do
you guys like ski and that was like do
you like i'll sell you cocaine
did you know that yeah that i knew i
knew skiing meant coke okay well
prostitution is legal in new york no
what do you mean yeah or it's
decriminalized which pretty much means
it's legal
really yeah manhattan to stop
prosecuting prostitution
wow as of last week yeah well i gotta go
guys
get a
prostate
prosthesis trust a frost exam um so i
need this treadmill right so i found the
guy i found that 150 come pick it up so
i get my buddy mike botch we get in my
car with a red chill ever
i might have put up the pictures of my
car that red celebrity station wagon
where i put the detailing on it okay it
says these nuts oh yeah yeah
so we get to this guy's house we pull up
he actually lived on in staten island um
near like uh i forget the name of the
block but it's where red men used to
live you ever see the red man cribs no
he he's like living in like a town house
in staten island yeah and he he does the
cribs it's really funny he was the first
one to ever do he was the first one to
ever do a cribs in like a place that
wasn't really like great
and his cousin is sleeping on the floor
in one room
he gets out of bed and he's cuz he's
like don't mind this guy he steps over
and goes that's just my cousin and his
cousin's passed out on the living room
floor oh my god yeah this is when cribs
was at the height he did this
i mean it's hilarious though look at the
blinds
but it's actually pretty probably like
if you spruced it up it's actually
probably a nice piece of property right
ah at a decent house college guys i mean
it's just i mean look it's not clean
he's hysterical i love red man yeah
shout out to reggie noble why do you
ever meet him yeah i actually have a few
times he doesn't know me i know who i am
but i've met him i think he still lives
on staten island's on the floor
look
you think he still lives on staten
island i think he i think that islands
like he might be he's from staten island
right or he's not from brick city babe
he's from newark
but he he reps newark but but he's on
staten island a lot this we have a we
have a um
we have a streetwear company here called
richmond hood shout out richmond hood uh
and he's he's like boys with them we're
heavily involved with them he does
skateboarding and photography a lot and
he hangs out at all like the standalone
street festivals we have and stuff red
man's like around
interesting
eminem's favorite rapper
what eminem's favorite rapper it's red
man yes wow yeah yeah that song to like
i think it's
i think it's till i collapse where he
goes i got a list here's the order of my
list and it goes reggie jay-z tupac and
biggie andre from outcast jada corrupt
nas and then me reggie is red reggie's
reggie no yeah red man yeah we're
positive reggie's billion
it's not you sure it's not it's not
reggie miller it's red men okay reggie
miller
i don't know no but he's talking about
rappers yeah but i don't know yeah
20 20 weirdest things you could buy on
craigslist antique hand crank women's
vibrating adult toy get it get it with
the hey babe card get it
let's get it
and lock it down
we'll autograph it we'll raffle it off
a magical horse i don't know what that
is belly button lint gross i don't want
that human soul whatever that is idiot
idiot dog
buffy the vampire slayer action figures
how's that sound has them already
totally awesome so here's what happened
right so i go to this guy's house right
so like it's right it's it's in red
man's community it's like near the
salvation army
it's not far and um
we go this guy opens the door and this
guy it's a single white dude tall big
guy maybe like in his 40s so it's a
single white male not a single single
white male but i was like
no joke i was like 20. right so this guy
was like 45 50 maybe right right he
answered the door in a bathrobe right
and no shirt underneath like tattered
shorts good body he's hit no okay he
wasn't fat or anything but he wasn't
regretting not yeah he's
not shaving his hair's bed head he
looked like a guy what time of the day
is this this was like
in the afternoon like noon yeah right he
just looked like a guy that was
his house was a mess right he just
looked like he was maybe he had a drug
problem drinking problem or maybe he was
just like depressed or maybe he just was
like the [ __ ] was falling apart there
was no woman in the man's life that's
for sure for sure because the place was
like looking like whatever probably not
even his mama i was
not even his mama and i was actually a
little bit hesitant but i had my friend
with me but he opened the door and he's
like towering over us and he's like oh
hey guys and he's like all like weird
and like you know like he's like ah and
he goes yeah yeah come in he goes what
are you here for i guess he listed other
things
so like uh the treadmill and he goes all
right right to trim up
come on follow me listen babe this is
one of those ones where it's like
we get ad copies for certain ads you're
like oh let's try to look at magic spoon
i don't have to i don't need it four
neck cubs 140 calories 12 13 grams of
protein 14 grams 13 14 protein the the
flavors peanut butter frosted fruity
blueberry cocoa cinnamon you could order
a pack of four you get five dollars off
i don't got to look i don't have to do
the coffee i eat it i live it it's keto
friendly it's guilt-free i love this
cereal i do with almond milk milk and
bananas personally you don't have to do
that i used to put bananas in my cereal
i haven't done it in years and now i'm
going to do it again you ready for this
ready for what i did ready for what i
did this morning i'm ready coco flavored
magic spoon banana almond milk with
bananas
wow that's what i did you're really
getting an inventive and with your
breakfast well magic spoon you could do
whatever the hell you want you can
inventive because
you know one better the box i think it's
about seven ounces seven ounces
interesting i think it is
magicspoon.com hey babe get the custom
bundle use the promo code hey babe get
five dollars off your order so if you
want five bucks off the magic spoon all
you gotta do is go to magicspoon.com hey
babe put in the promo code hey babe i'm
telling you i genuinely in my heart
believe this it is the best cereal i've
ever had and it's guilt-free yes there's
all the other cereals that you used to
eat love as a kid the fruit loses
cinnamon toast crunch
but it makes you fat it's sugary if you
want to have those once in a while fine
but if you want to stay on your diet if
you want to stay healthy health is
wealth as they say magic spoon's the
answer that's it
this podcast sponsored by betterhelp
betterhelp will assess your needs and
match you with your own licensed
professional therapist you could start
communicating with someone in under 48
hours not a crisis line okay it's a
self-help it's not a self-help line it's
professional counseling yes and it's
done securely online there's a broad
range of expertise available uh and even
if it's not locally available in your
area you can still get it the service is
available for clients worldwide except i
would presume china and north korea
because they don't really have access to
the internet but if they did if they
don't have our internet service they may
have a version of their better health
there and go do that but i would say
north korea and china at the moment are
not allowing american servers to be done
so i or european servers to be done so i
would say betterhelp.com
worldwide except those two countries a
little caveat but most of the world but
you can if you do have the internet you
can log on send the message to your
counselor at any time we have a special
offer special offer and if you do have
access to the people of north korea
please let them know yeah special offer
betterhelp.com
hey babe that's
b-e-t-t-e-r-h-e-l-p-dot-com
hey babe 10 off your first month kids
that's right tempers over your first
month at betterhelp.com
hey babe slash hey babe go check out
better help your nut bags
[Laughter]
so he opens the door the house smell
yeah it was it was not like it was not
kept right right and so he goes oh we
got to go upstairs and we go up this
little staircase it's a main staircase
but it's like this little staircase up
the side it was like a townhouse and it
was carpeted all carpeted the carpet was
a little dirty and there was cds all
over the steps so i was walking up the
steps we all follow him in his bathrobe
shirtless and we're trying not to step
on any cds or whatever when we get to
the top of the floor and there's like
two little rooms almost like a little
den that he turned into and he opens it
and the room is a mess and the
treadmill's in there right and it's it's
a it's a big treadmill like one of the
big ones yeah and he's like yeah he goes
you know we just gotta
work together to get it out of here
and so i was like okay and i'm like but
it was like a thousand dollar 1200
treadmill but you would get it for how
much 150 is what you listed it for oh my
god so but the treadmill looked like it
was like it wasn't like in new condition
right
so we got to pick it up the thing had to
be a couple of hundred pounds easy right
easy and it's huge you know those big
treadmills yeah of course yeah so my
friend and me get one and the guy gets
the other end oh god that's a disaster
i'm in the house less than five minutes
me and this guy and my friend mike are
carrying like a 200 pound treadmill down
this narrow steps and he's this guy
definitely was on something i don't know
what and we're going i mean we have to
rest it every couple of steps and as i'm
going down you hear the jewel cases just
smashing under our feet of all the cds
that were on the steps it's like crack
i'm so sorry is that guy just try to
avoid the cds and then we get to the
bottom of the steps right and
so we set it down and i'm literally
breathing heavy and craigslist's like a
known thing like you you you bargain
that's what you do you never accept
someone's for it's like a digital flea
market right so i i look at my friend
now we had this whole plan to like
bargain with him like we're going to say
and i'll go i go listen you know i know
it said 150 in the end i go but
i was wondering you know if you could do
a little better
right and the guy looks at me goes
he goes i had a he goes i swear to god
it's the exact words that came out of
this he goes
i had a lot of
he said i had a lot of good use with
that machine
and he was like
he was like staring
off into nothing that's it that's the
title of the episode i had a lot of good
years with that machine i had a lot of
good years with that machine yeah and
like there was clothes hanging on it
when we got upset and so it's at the
bottom of the steps all the plastic from
all the cd bro it's all over and he's
had a lot of good years done she and i
go uh i was like speaking of i was like
i know you said 150. is there any way
you could do a little better than that
it's a little steep for me and he goes i
guess
i'll take it
he went from 150 to bargain and he goes
take it take it he didn't say 140 110
125.
take it take it zero he went too i had a
lot of good years of machine dialogue
machine and take it it's the two things
he said to me and i was like why and
then my friend brought it out to the car
and i had their red station wagon and i
popped the back and i was in the back
and my friend went to the front and i
went to the front my friend was in the
back and he pushed it in and closed the
thing and it fit because you put the
seats down it went from the back of the
station wagon to the front to the very
very front to the steering wheel and i
went i said thank you so much he goes
all right he's in this bathroom he waves
goodbye i get in the front seat my
friend gets in the front seat i close
the door i look up my entire windshield
is shattered because oh my god i pushed
the treadmill all the way in and it was
too long for the car and i hit the front
windshield and shattered the whole
windshield and i just looked up and i go
what the f
like when did that happen because it
wasn't like pushing on it was still like
this far away so i guess it like settled
and my friend was like i don't know and
i'm like did we do that my friend go i
go did you do that and because he pushed
it and he goes no he goes maybe like
when we were inside like kids were
playing ball and they hit the windshield
and then my friend we started cracking
up and like
as he drove away he's like i probably
did it
how much did it cost to fix the
windshield i fixed it never fix it
shattered windshield to the car
never fixed it ever ever drove around
with a shattered windshield for the life
of that car which was how much longer
it wasn't kane to knock along no it was
it was long it was like two years which
is and caught you guys pretty much i
came to knockout
god bless god i have a question as a
germaphobe you hear the guy talk about
sweating on this machine
i cleaned the whole thing but then the
problem with that machine uh was that i
never could use it because the belt
was too loose so when i turned on i
would take a step it would stop
while my when my foot came down and then
when it came up it would start again so
it ended up being a piece of [ __ ] i had
to throw it away anyway and i ended up
buying one from sports sports authority
so it didn't work so how many times did
you actually use it i tried to use it
like a handful of times until i was like
i'm going to kill myself on this thing
it was such a house one of those mini
smaller ones for like 400 500 bucks at
sports authority but if you would i
never use that really never hardly do
you have a treadmill in the house today
i do not wow yeah
yeah i don't i'm not a treadmill guy
people keep getting killed on the
peloton treadmill
what yeah really you heard this yeah
it's it's all the time emails are weird
treadmill fails are great they haven't
seen that when they're running or they
step on an inspect and they just shoot
to the back yeah yeah kids keep getting
sucked under it oh my god yeah peloton
recalls treadmills after dozens of
injuries and a death yes no good on the
peloton peloton bike shout out good good
stuff but the treadmill you don't want
that
they called all treadmills so they had
troubles now they don't have treadmills
i don't yeah i guess that's how they
died after being pulled underneath it i
just ordered a peloton to the house and
i it accidentally charged me twice
really yeah i mean a whole dispute they
said they can't
get
it so i called peloton i said i only
want one it accidentally charged me for
two they go okay but the order's already
placed i said yeah i know but i don't
want two pelotons and they're like
there's a long process like it's a
process for us to
you know get
they said we won't send two will only
send one but you got a whole hollow
balloon you may get charged for two
and then you have to figure it out with
amex and then amex told me
you know to just you know dispute the
charge fine but you may not get the
credit back on your credit card for like
90 days you get that credit that credit
back from amex on your thing i'll buy
the other peloton off you you want a
peloton yeah okay
and how much is it how much is the belt
on
uh
like it was like 2500
american yeah but but it comes with
shoes and weights oh it comes with the
shoes i'll take it the guy comes with
the shirt one of these shoes because you
need certain shoes special shoes to lock
in you've got to wear special so it's
like both the same size we're of worst
size off i think yeah but i could just
but you could just get but i'm giving
you the credit so you could just you
could just you pick your shoe size it's
like bowling shoes but for a peloton
have you been on a peloton never what
made you invest 2 500 american dollars
on on a bicycle
i know it's sweeping the niche but is
that something that you
you you want to like
has someone vouched for it that's a
hefty price i was just sitting at home
myself and then you have to subscribe
right to the classes on top of that yeah
that must have been terrible for that
poor child that was dragged on the
treadmill and the class lady teaching
the class was like come on
she's like get off your asses
jesus
sarah i don't see you
do they see you
i think no right no they can't see
everybody i mean i hope that family owns
peloton now they need to yeah
i mean is it peloton's fault or could it
happen with any treadmill no it started
sucking pets under it too oh god it's
got a lot of pets yeah
yeah so
so yeah i think i think i just saw the
commercial and i got peloton what does
that mean that name
i think it's just you saw the commercial
and got hooked yeah you know you can get
a used call for twenty five hundred
dollars
my first three car my first car was like
my first car ever that i bought was
eleven hundred dollars and my next car
was five hundred and fifty dollars but
i'm paying it i put it on layaway i
haven't went layaway in a long time i
went layaway you went layaway
installments
are they interest-free interest-free
layaway okay yeah i think it's
interest-free i didn't look yeah i heard
there's a crazy way for peloton because
during the pandemic everybody wanted a
gym in the house and then there was a
run on him i ordered mine wednesday it's
coming tomorrow friday
so it's coming right away oh yeah that
peloton is killing people on the tremolo
they're competing with covert and more
ways than one yes because people want to
who's going to kill more
french peloton means
okay
but it's often used with the meaning
group so ball group
bicycling context okay okay for a
marathon or a sporting event okay
okay well i'm sure that peloton uh
instance was
a
an accident and they're doing all they
can to fix it and our hearts go out to
all the pets and people that have
sucked under the peloton yeah sorry i
mean
oh that's got gloom and doom all of a
sudden
it's a very sad place this has been hey
babe
no uh peloton yes so i'm gonna get it
and then and then we'll see what happens
i'm not a big guy i'm not a big spin guy
i'm not a big spin bike guy
but the family wanted it so we got it
for him and then i i don't know spin
always spin class once people started
crying really yeah it hurts my ass the
seat always hurts my ass i have although
i have a fat ass i have a i have
protruding bones from my ass no my ass
hurts on bicycle seats all the time i
got to get those ones that look like
lazy boy recliner seats right like on
the on the bike i got to be honest with
you i'm pretty loopy right now from
either the dayquil or the um
what's it called binoco
yeah i'm pretty loopy from the baroqua
and the nyquil yeah yeah yeah this is
supposed to be non drows but i never i
don't know if that ever works
so how do you feel right now do you feel
you can go on
oh yeah i mean my heart can go on like
you're like straight saline straight
saline yeah heart can go on but but but
i do feel i do feel
loopy i feel loopy doopy and i want to
feel loopy almost and we are on folks
the last tissue
not only was that a new box i swear to
god i had taken the remnants of the old
box before i gave you that and stuffed
it in with the new box so you have gone
through
over one box of tissues in the last hour
65 three-ply tissues in one box there
you go plus another 10 so let's say 75
tissues
wow 65 tissues a box i went through them
all look
but what are you going to do not a whole
bag of tissues what are you going to do
now
you use my shirt no i'll go back to
toilet paper you can't use your
roosevelt shell or as well roosevelt
roosevelt
fdr delano hotel in miami shout out
miami shout out to equator shout out t
shout out to yeah shout out to equator
facts about the equator it's halfway
between the north and south pole we know
that it's zero degrees lats we knew that
an equator divides the planet into a
northern hem and a southern hem we knew
that the earth is widest at its equator
we knew that i mean tell me something i
don't know equator the distance around
the earth at the equator and its
circumference is
24 901 miles i didn't know that didn't
know that i didn't know that i probably
read that before i didn't retain that i
didn't know that at all if you live on
the equator you will experience the
quickest rates of sunrise and sunset in
the world taking a matter of minutes
what yeah because i guess it's got the
least to travel because you're dead sent
these people also have a constant 12
hours of daylight through the year day
and night day and night sorry oh wow so
there's no oh i wouldn't want 12. wait
that means it's only life for 12 hours a
day that's not that much right not that
much seven to seven like in summertime
we get what 16 hours yeah don't we we
get like nine ish and then like to like
no joke it's like six in the morning the
sunrise yeah so nine hours might as well
you got 15 hours yeah yeah i haven't
seen a good sunrise lately you have it
you have it
yeah
i have yeah yeah it was less have you
saw a good sunrise no i watched them oh
you said rise and set what yeah as a com
i do that as a matter of course yeah
yeah i do i'm not joking i watched i
watched a set three times last week you
watched the second watch the set
rises are a little bit more infrequent
but i make sure i shoehorn them in it
was a super moon last week at about 7 14
a.m really yeah you saw it no you
couldn't do it but i'm just saying i
have my hands on the pulse right right
okay okay good but that's good to know
yeah what do you like better a sunrise
or a set i would have to say they're
both really nice
i like a sun
rise only because i know that pancakes
are coming soon okay yeah okay sunset i
kind of feel like you had your day
already yeah there's not much to look
forward to it's more romantic though
sunset are you gonna propose i do it at
a sunset not a sunrise i do it on a
sunrise really you propose that a
sunrise for me nothing makes me hornier
than a sunrise okay so then you're gonna
get your loved one in the dark first
you're gonna have to tell a fib
why are you bringing me out this early
hey
who's yeah who's counting you know what
i mean how about this because if you
ever propose how you gonna do it do you
know
what would i do can we can we can we
crowdsource your proposal
i would if i was gonna can we take we'll
take the top 10 suggestions and then put
it out to vote
we'll keep it from vinnie that's just
okay that's the last sentence yeah i'll
start it okay
so remember that story we were doing on
on one of those episodes where that
fisherman got stuck in the whale's mouth
you remember like the whale literally
ain't a fisherman high tension situation
i literally i was thinking about it i
said if i was in that situation
in stuck in the whale's mouth he started
punching the injuries
i can't think of anything that would
calm me down in that situation can you i
i would the only thing i could think of
is throwing in maybe like a fistful of
sunday scary cbd gummies if you if you
think if we gave that whale a fistful of
sunday scary cbd gummies it would get so
relaxed that the fisherman would have
been able to just swim right out of it
right back out because no contractions
anymore you're just chilling you're
vibing you're in the atlantic ocean in a
whale's mouth sunday scaries keeps me
calm that's it that would be the vibe if
they he would come out of that not even
upset he would be making puns like i had
a whale of a good time this is how chill
sunday scares this sunday scaries must
be getting high after their own supply
because you know what they're doing now
you know what the new offer is sunday
scariest.com put in the promo code hey
babe 25 off biente cinco percent
promo code hey babe that's all you got
to do you get 25 off i mean what's the
difference you get something for a
quarter one-fourth off but also as big
he said in the ten crack commandments
don't get high of your own supply which
sunday scares has got to be getting
higher off their own supply because
they're just giving it away pretty much
for free i mean i would anyway if i
worked at sunday scaries sunday
scaries.com promo code hey babe don't do
crack do cbd
babe you vitamin up right i love
vitamins i used to take i used to eat
flintstones vitamins like they were
candy and go you have a w yeah and i
stopped and i think i have a vitamin
deficiency now we do have a vitamin
deficiency i feel like i do honestly man
if you me and pimp were just talking
about this we thought that you had a
vitamin deficiency because he came in
today why no yeah and we said he looks a
little like deficient he looks a vitamin
deficient i can't and we could have put
a finger on it and then homeless pimp
said because i wasn't even thinking
about this homeless pimp said to me goes
he's a vitamin deficiency why doesn't he
just go to ritual because you guys take
her to the ritual and you love it and it
puts a pep in your step yes it's a multi
yes it's a multivitamin and and and
imagined it's got all the nutrients that
you that you could possibly need
including vitamin d3 which everybody
needs it's only two daily pills
and it's delivered they deliver it right
to our doors by the way this is good no
i was gonna say normally nine times out
of ten you gotta go get the vitamins you
got to go here you got to go there you
got a drugstore this is coming right to
your doorstep boom you need vitamins you
never run out it's traceable too that's
the one thing i think that it's cool
you'll always know where the nutrients
come from that you're taking thanks to
rituals one-of-a-kind visible visible
supply chain yeah uh it's designed with
your life stage in mind now i know a lot
about rituals
and it's like you said it's traceable
it's like swallowing a gps that's right
so available for men women and teens
ritual multivitamins are scientifically
developed to help support different life
stages it makes healthy habits easy get
your key nutrients without the bs i
should listen to what i'm saying i'm
gonna start taking ritual this week
definitely rituals offering our
listeners ten percent off during your
first three months visit ritual.com hey
babe to start your ritual to die
here's what i do
if i was going to propose yeah
i'd get i'd i'd get down on one knee
yeah too it'd be weird if you got down
on two one yeah yeah on two knees
you know what everyone gets down on one
knee yeah you know them out of the water
i get into a full
indian style sit
sitting down okay what pose is that
that's a yoga pose yoga pose i'd sit
down yeah i'd be in a warrior pose um
i'd sit down what i'd do is i'd have
both the kids i'd have i have my
daughter my stepson
they'd come in holding a box
inside that box
she would rummage through
there would be
red balls and blue balls through the
cubes
i'd put the engagement inside the cube
she opened the card he'd be like hi this
is dwayne wade he just wants him to know
that he loves you very much yes that's
100 what i do that's 1000 what i do is
i'd have it in the cube yeah i'd make
that a part of my proposal by the time
you see the sunset it's actually gone
five facts you didn't know about sunsets
did you know that what
by the time you see the sunset it's
actually gone no it's okay so they're
right on that one sunsets happen because
the earth's atmosphere
dot dot dot none of these are full
sentences right yeah pollution causes
prettier sunsets
interesting
pollution does cost prettier yeah i
guess they kind of do because it gives
it like a nice glimmer you know what
what does this that mean at the bottom
there pimp that fifth bullet point
red sky at night shepard's delight
red sky in the morning shepherds take
warning
it's a true quote it says
red sky at night shepherd's delight you
know what i've never had ever in my life
once
shepherd's pie
yeah i don't know if i have either
different shepherd's pie i don't know i
think what is it send shepherd's pie
we'll
we'll give you guys the p.o box
sen make a shepherd's pie send it to us
we'll eat it live on the show what is it
maybe i have had it when i was when i
was in europe or something
british comfort food classic love by all
well not sal and i this is a classic
recipe using ground lamb i've never had
lamb cooked with vegetables and guinness
for an extra flavor boost topped with
fluffy mashed potatoes and baked
all right so fluffy mash and veg but i
don't think i want ground lamb i'm not a
lamb guy same recipe ground beef is
using a cottage pie never heard of a
cottage pie i've also never had cottage
cheese i've actually never even stayed
in a cottage wow yeah you have so much
to you have so much i've never stayed in
a cottage and i've never had cottage
cheese that's a true fact and i've
certainly never had cottage pie yeah i
never had cottage pie cottage cheese
i've had and not too bad
i love cottages though i love a cottage
really oh my god what's the last time
you've seen fairy tales like hansel and
gretel and [ __ ] no i'd love to stay in
one but when is when does the
opportunity arise so you can stay in the
cottage you can make it happen you
control your own destiny if you want to
stay in the cottage tomorrow you can
make it happen you just don't walk
around thinking about how you're going
to stay in a cottage it's not out of
reach
i love a cottage like a keebler elf
lives in there with me yeah there's a
lantern hanging off like a tree but
that's lit with gas or like a fire in it
that's a banter with fire i feel like
that like a gingerbread house yeah i
would love to live in it you ever see
like those christmas villages that you
put under there oh i love a christmas
cottages my dream in life is to go to
germany or austria for christmas
dream i know austria will be amazing
right should we do it oh i would love
let's go
switzerland
is that the same thing no but the church
i want to be in one of those mountain
the bottom of the mountain little towns
yeah and you look and it's all like a
cottage yeah it's all like
here's i want to live underneath the
christmas tree
in a christmas
village like a fake christmas village
yeah in real life i want to
i want to die and come back to life as a
piece of a nativity set that would be
that's what i want to do that's for you
i want to be a figurine underneath the
christmas tree in one of those villages
you know like there'll be a train going
around then all of a sudden there's a
little skating rink yes and then there's
a general store a lot of lamp posts yes
i like that like that love a lamp i want
to live in that right yeah let's do that
how do we do that
what's what's the what's the what's the
most what's the closest real life
example of that take me there
you know what's the best
what is the most picturesque christmas
village in the world i'm going to guess
that i think there's a place
i think there's a place called like
strood off austria or something like
that i want to feel like i'm in a snow
globe you know what i'm saying yeah what
is it
taos new mexico that's what i was
thinking no
mexico you were right though but with
that austria wait where are those photos
from though pimpy
that doesn't look like christmas village
yeah that looks like that like where is
that
yeah what is that oh that's great that's
what i want
yeah
wow they really exist
soul then california bad raga
switzerland i don't love it no woodstock
vermont no franklin tennessee certainly
not i want the picture that we saw that
yeah what's the picture that we saw look
at maybe it's europe our house denmark
is a keeper so far yeah
nacho noches
louisiana williamsburg virginia shadow
colonial williamsburg saint augustine
florida first settlement in the u.s
that looks very colmar france is a
keeper that looks like hebrew
newport beach cali alexandria virginia
can't be warm no warm clouds no no it's
got to be cold rothenberg over dow
talbert germany looks promising
[Music]
remember when we were in aspen oh that
was a nice little cute little village
remember the fart that i ripped it out
yes
it reverberated through the mountains do
you do you really remember like how
crazy that was shot through like three
blocks keep talking because of the way
the acoustics were at the foothills of
the mountain you could be like yo and
you heard yo yo yo and he he farted and
it literally like shot like four blocks
like i saw someone like a family walking
four blocks away and they went like that
yeah now is this crazier than the fart
he played previously on the show that
far sounded more like uh like the
beginnings of what's happening no it was
it was it was that that this fart was
i'm sorry it sounded like uh what's that
like home improvement he's like
yeah i'm sorry that this is like fart
heavy but but uh this podcast lately but
but um this fart and then what also was
great is we got our reactions me and
sal's reactions of us laughing
hysterically listen like we did uh a
watchback of the fart
that i posted the reaction shot yeah no
because also we were in aspen and the
air was thin
yes
i legitimately remember almost passing
are you going to find this
because we've posted on the instagram
well he's finding that this is a crazy
effect uh when we open our eyes i got it
we leave the outside world as it is
right now but we are actually living
slightly in the past it takes time for
information from our eyes to reach our
brain where it is processed analyze and
ultimately integrate it into
consciousness
interesting i wonder what that lag is
that's trippy i mean we're natural sex
computers yeah probably a tiny second
here we go this here
guys literally this town
is so beautiful
it's like actually makes me emotional
[Laughter]
and then and then here is
[Music]
and then this is
we're on the floor laughing
this is from january 5th 2019.
no it has to be before that no [ __ ] that
janu
january 7th january 5th and 7th 2019.
really
2019 so that's when i wrote my aspen bit
it must have been yeah it was that day i
gotta get toilet paper go for it babe
70
70 milliseconds have passed
by the time we process the information
that we see with our eyes i don't know
how long that is that's got to be
well i know how long it is it's 70
milliseconds
but how many milliseconds are in a
second a thousand got a million
a millionth
i mean it's gonna be a million right a
thousand
like a millennia
right what is
so 70 of those
so it's like
almost like a little less than one tenth
of a second so but it's actually pretty
substantial because if you do that in
the course of your life you're really
like
minutes behind like when you die you
really died
10 minutes ago how so i'm just saying
like if you if you cumulatively every
time you open our eyes and something
catches up with us right it's one tenth
of a second behind that it gets to our
brains yeah so yeah is there any animal
that lives in the moat that can
just see things as they're happening i
don't know i also don't know how we know
the dogs are colorblind yeah i don't
know either and to be honest with you i
don't want to know i'm not ready for
that how do we all know that we're not
like i don't understand like
yeah because well do you know that do
you know that like what you see as blue
or red
or green
i see it as that but it's a little bit
different is that true that's true we
all see it a little bit different that's
weird to me yeah there's no definite way
to confirm that we know anything at all
yes sentence epistemology how do we know
that you know what you know
there is no definite way to confirm we
know anything that only from our direct
experience can we claim any knowledge
about the world it's hard to imagine a
world that exists outside of what we can
perceive
well because that's the thing that's the
thing
the things people google how is it
possible that we know anything at all
through our innate and autonomous human
reason and the methods of science we
cannot only know the universe but we can
infer at least something of what god is
like through our innate and autonomous
human reason including the methods of
science we can know the universe i don't
know what i just read or say me neither
here's the thing
is really what th what is happening
though is there is a thing where it's
like more like alternate realities as
opposed to
like living in the past future present
like there's a reality where like
your hat is slightly to the other side
but is that true
pimp says it is so it has to be i mean
it's movie stuff right no but so i mean
i think that's what ghosts are like it's
just two different dimensions where the
coding is thin in the video game
i know but you believe in ghosts
i believe that it's probably like
alternate dimensions where god just got
lazy and it's just bad like a bad video
game you could see through them god i
had this is like a high conversation in
college yeah
there has to be something i believe in
something there has to be something i
don't know what whatever religion wants
to say or yeah that's fine but there's
got to be something well we're saying
right now i want to know do you think in
our lifetime we will i know we covered
aliens in the past but i just want to
ask you do you think that we will before
we go that we will see
aliens or because you know how people
are like um you got to be careful like
it's global warming and and you know the
ocean is being depleted and that's going
to have you know that's going to have a
domino effect and we're worried about
all this stuff as far as like earth
ecologically like greenpeace stuff but
all that's out the window if the aliens
just come down and want to take over
[ __ ] yeah like no one's anticipating
that we have like scientists being like
well before we're in trouble with the
ice caps melting will be you know
every like x amount that we think an
inch but but no one's just like at any
given moment aliens that come down
[ __ ] up and it doesn't matter about any
of those calculations i agree with you
100 and that's why i think about a lot
too would you rather die like a normal
death like die alone or whatever like
just just you're dying and like you know
the world keeps going on or would you
rather be part of a mass extinction
oh god i'm gonna get i'm gonna have a
full on a panic attack right now i'm
just asking i don't like my mind to go
to these places at all i think i would
just rather just let me pass this is the
way i get when i'm taking everybody out
with me yeah now i saw something crazy
on the news 60 minutes did an hour on
aliens the other night 60 minutes okay
and they interviewed these two people
who witnessed something off of a like a
navy you know where they carry all the
jets
and they pulled up on one of these
little ufos that was like boiling the
ocean a little bit in the middle of
nowhere like doing something to the
ocean so it's like what if they're just
going to rip all the water
there was a six i like that you said 60
minutes did an hour on it yeah yeah you
did an hour 60 minutes in an hour's
special
like 15 minute segments on both oh
really yeah how much 60 minutes yeah
that's the thing that's most
mind-blowing to me is now like everybody
talks about aliens like of course
they're real where 25 years ago 60
minutes would never do would never
report on this it would be mastery in
the streets but i will say this like
also now we're all like way too
comfortable why isn't them necessary in
the streets like everyone's like yeah
okay there's aliens but like nobody
cares i don't know how is nobody caring
and then this happened yesterday what
happened yesterday if ufos are aliens
obama hopes humanity would find common
ground so obama knows for sure that
there aren't
um i mean i hope we find common ground
you don't know how about this you don't
know if they're gonna they're gonna come
down and solve our problems i don't know
what they're waiting for how about this
aliens if you're listening and we know
you are how about this like calm down
cure cure stuff for us please i know a
guy
who is personal friends with president
barack obama
yes
no it's it's personal friends with
president barack obama i'll tell you his
name after the show i mean personal like
for real like this is for real he's
friends with him yeah like very very
close yeah he told me
that he had dinner once at the obama's
residence after he was president like
when he's just hanging out like in
chicago wherever he lives
that
he asked him how does he live i think
chicago or dc he asked him about aliens
right and all that stuff and he was like
honestly man he's like at this point he
was like there's some things i can't
just tell anybody he's like but he's
like there are this is what president
obama said president obama i love it
he's like i can't talk much about it and
then your friend helps you yeah you got
to hear what obama said now like guys
you got to hear what obama said yeah
yeah because
well what he said was because he really
didn't say much because what he said was
which that was mind-blowing i had ten
thousand other questions for him after
this but he walked away is
is it
but he slapped me and walked away yeah
he slapped me
he said [ __ ]
yeah so he let me tell you what obama
said to me he said this slap and then
just walks away
but what he said that was like
truly like
mind-shattering well i was like wait
what obama said and again this guy is a
viable source like a guy who like
legitimately like i know is like a
personal friend and he said that obama
looked him dead in the eyes and said
this has been hey babe
[Music]
don't be afraid don't be ashamed don't
hesitate to say hey babe hey babe hey
babe hey